I I actually made a video about this a
long time ago and it was
um basically it was along the lines of
like black women don't have the luxury
to be feminine because what I said in
the video is that like obviously a lot
of
um a lot of black people in general yeah
we come from trauma we come from
dysfunctional backgrounds and stuff like
that and listen I understand like I've
got three sisters like I've got nieces
like to get what I'm saying and I
understand that just the fact of a lot
of Us coming from single parent homes
that's a huge fact is so underrated and
you know this whole like praising single
motherhood is very very dangerous and
damaging to the community and this is
this is a manifestation of of of this um
this problem or this this um
point of origin right that a lot of
there's a lot of divide between the men
and women because again all right boom
you have a household yeah just the mom's
there you have the boys you have the
girls yeah the girls never have no dad
so they've not grown up with no
protection or provision from a man a man
that's showing them unconditional love
without requesting something sexual in
return yeah so they've never seen a man
and woman black man black woman
functionally functionally having a
relationship and having a household so
now all they've seen is their mum be
independent they emulate that their moms
probably told them girl you better get
your money you don't need no man don't
never depend on a man blah blah blah
um add the in feminism on top of that
now you've got women that don't know how
to you know couple up with a with a man
in general you get what I'm saying they
go out into the world and now they have
been influenced by cardi B city girls uh
Megan the stallion all of these kind of
people nah and now they they they're
going after Rich guys fogs rappers
athletes blah blah blah these guys have
got options they're top tier they can
run around and cheat and do whatever
this happens a few times one time two
time three times their heart's been
broken three times now now they're
bitter now they're just like all men are
dogs All Nigerian men cheat blah blah
blah blah blah all of this and then bruh
it's done do you know what I'm saying
and at the end of the day every man
regardless of what color the man is just
wants peace
a lot of times guys will forego looks
for peace that's why you see some guys
you might see some black guys out there
that let's keep it real you see some
black guys and it's like oh he's with a
white woman and she's overweight
why are they with am I lying though why
why why is it why is why why is it you
see black men with with women outside
the race who you are you know not not
the best looking because usually that
woman's probably giving him peace of
mind and emptying his balls and keeping
his belly full without the headache and
it's just like what the brother said
it's not fair because as I said black
women don't have the luxury
to be just feminine and dainty because
it comes from dysfunctional pasts you
know I'm saying I'll let you go and this
is one of the things that I think since
we always mention the word
accountability if we're coming from
single parent households as well and
we're always looking at women do this
women do that now when are we gonna hold
men responsible for also making a change
that allows for their sisters to grow
into a world where they're more accepted
because yeah we and I even say I mix
race but I suffered a lot of racism in
Portugal and here in England right I
know what it feels like to be a black
girl because I was labeled as a black
girl and yeah you're picked last all the
time and you grow with a lot you grow
with a lot of insecurities and then when
you have men that you're you're like the
fathers before us that came in did a lot
of things that obviously they do come
from trauma and then they're now here
running away from the German going for
another race and leaving us out to drive
when actually the black woman as he said
is the most loyal to the black man is
probably the one that stays in takes
care of him the best because she
understands his struggle but nobody
wants to understand a black woman's
struggle and that's what is not fair and
if we want to actually continue to you
know grow and become a better you know
Community we have to also look at the
fact bro it's your turn to not stop
protecting your sister because your
mother protected you the women have been
doing the work behind the scenes for
time so I know men are actually going to
stand up and say you know what let me
relax let me actually speak to my to my
uh black girlfriend somebody that I do
like and actually speak to her and say I
should you know what maybe you could
change this maybe can you try this I
don't I know you may be upset because of
this just start like reasoning because
it's not it's not fair it really is not
and then black girls are the loud angry
this this that these times they're not
look Nicole sitting there peacefully
acutely simple not every black girl is
like that you know what I mean not every
black girl is even going to display her
anger with fingers in your face like
it's not like that all the time so yeah
nobody says no but that's generally The
Stereotype that sticks because then even
the black man will fortify that
stereotype so even your own race is
against you girl you don't have a chance
but it's not it's not one-sided though
they're just the same way a black man
can say the exact same thing you said in
parallel exact same thing in parallel so
I think everybody needs to be held
accountable and as I said at the top of
the show I think I feel like women are
less likely to accept accountability
you're saying let me give you an example
in the USA I can talk about the USA
right that I noticed that a lot of women
from my community seem to have a problem
with staying in shape staying in the
right weight class is actually a really
big problem and in America in general is
a big problem right now as black men you
know a lot of us we like to play sports
like I did you know all of that stuff
you know we would prefer to be with
women that you know aesthetically suit
us now if you come out on a public say I
was just sitting here on my own and I
said that
what what do you think what kind of
rebuttals or feedback do you think I
would get from black women
well the same way that there's some that
have issues with their body they somehow
got the bangiest bodies you've ever seen
in fact that's not what every white
woman now wants to have a black woman
this is not why I asked you that's not
what I'm just telling you what you're
doing to tell me what I didn't ask you
now I'll ask you a straight question
what would it be the rebuttals if
there's a rebuttal that's what somebody
would say do you think that would be the
common rebuttal from black women
uh it would be fat shaming it'd be fat
shaming your misogynist your body
shaming uh you hate us that's what it
would be but there's some white girls
have issues with their weight too so do
the Mexicans they're actually largely
obese aren't they yeah I said I said in
America in general yeah I said they got
a problem
no but I'm giving you an example of
accountability because at the end of the
day
um that is one of the biggest things
that is taking out black women in that
country
so obviously that's a big issue it's not
even just about attractive black men
because there's a lot of black men that
will still date a black woman who's
overweight but I'm saying that there's
you said these things when are black men
gonna do this but like bro it goes both
ways the door swings both ways do you
get what I'm saying and it goes back to
that thing of take me as I am I'm sorry
I don't have to take nobody as they are
I don't I don't do ducks I don't
that's it and everybody that knows me in
real life knows that bro you know what
I'm saying so like like bro like at the
end of the day my last my last
ex-girlfriend she was half white half
Indian yeah and I remember one time I
was I was in Camden with her um that
Camden Market crap yeah and I remember I
seen some black girl and she was giving
me like a mad dirty look and I was
thinking bro like at the end of the day
bro like if you was alone and I was
alone the likelihood of you giving me
some kind of weird attitude if I
approach you is pretty high because it's
happened many many times this is not a
like one-off incident yeah I could be
wrong but you know it is where it is but
at the end of the day like people just
need to be accountable bro that's all
I'm saying sorry what did you want to
say you wanted to say something I just
wanted to go back to what she was saying
about um black men taking accountability
don't you think that later on in life
they kind of like correct themselves
because in this dating scene he's like
yeah black men are dating white women
because they are easier
I think they end up marrying black women
rather than white women because yeah
it's nice to date you and it's cool but
then the culture doesn't match
and you end up being like then you grow
up and later on in life you as a black
man would be like you know what like
now I'm in this time of my life and I'm
gonna just like pursue a black woman
because it doesn't work with a white
woman I agree with that it's like the
cultures and and it's the families as
well like you know um someone said it on
another podcast in here and they was
like oh yeah I might be dating a white
girl but her dad might be racist you're
gonna say one of my younger ones one of
my younger boys he was dating some girl
I know it was that exact same situation
like they'll be sitting down watching
football and then the dad would be like
oh yeah all you look alike and it's just
like
like what are you gonna marry into that
mm-hmm and then what if you have a kid
with the girl and I'm again I'm not
saying don't do it I'm just saying that
I'm agreeing with you that some some
guys may have that realization that raw
like
yeah like I'm basically merging my
lineage or that's that's this is going
to be my lineage from now on and also
another thing the likelihood of if you
have a mixed race child and you live in
the UK the probability that that makes
for a child is going to couple up with
another white person it's high very high
you can say especially if you live
outside of London Oh my days like that's
right most most of the mixed race boys
and girls I know outside of London
they're with white people
um
do you know I'm saying I have another
mate
um and he's got a YouTube channel and he
done it he said in the video that right
like he's a black guy up in North North
England he had he has kids with him or
what two kids I think with a white lady
and um basically he was sitting down in
his video and he said yo I just came to
the realization that raw like I've just
had kids with a white woman and the
reality is my kids won't
like 95 likelihood gun couple up with
another white person and then that's
that's me out yeah do you get what I'm
saying now I'm not saying that to say oh
yeah you shouldn't do interracial dating
I think live your movie do whatever
makes you happy whatever but I'm just
saying I agree with you on that point I
think that sometimes it can be just a
phase you're going through or you're
just having fun or whatever but some
people may may just think oh I'm just
gonna couple up with someone from my
community you know what I'm saying done
um and I don't know if it's this is more
of like a cultural thing or a race thing
but there's a lot of like unsaid
um things between someone that shares a
similar culture or a race that you
probably there's things that you
wouldn't necessarily need to say but
they're actually understood by the other
person unlike when you're with someone
from a different kind of race or culture
and it's kind of like
there's like the subliminal expectation
of things being there but then it's not
getting yeah you don't get it because
there's not that understanding there in
a sense
so yeah but that's that has to do with
culture not really with like the color
of your skin yeah it's true it's more of
a cultural thing rather than in a racial
thing as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible